Yuppie!
Moe, Moe, Moe!
Okae Nairi Nairi, Okae, Ojo-tamo!
Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello, welcome back to Portal 2, part 4!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
As you can see, I'm in my turret cosplay.
I'm in my turret cosplay at the moment.
Yes.
I feel like my outfit should be wide.
I'll make my main outfit white.
I don't know, but the turrets have black on them too.
I don't know.
Whatever, don't think about it.
Don't think about it.
Yippee!
Oh my gosh.
We are in chapter 5.
I believe.
We're in the middle of chapter 5.
We...
Where did we end?
We destroyed the neurotoxin.
We just got separated from Wheatley.
and he's like go find Gladys I'll meet you there so I guess
that's where we're headed
I kept looking at my settings taking a sip of coffee and
let's get into it let's get back into it I hope you guys are
good I hope you guys are doing so awesome today I hope you
guys are having a whenever this is going up.
I hope that these are fun for you as well because I've just
been having so much fun with the game.
Honestly, you know, I knew that I liked Portal 1 because,
well, I played it and I played it a long time ago, too,
before that and I knew that I liked it, so I'm really glad
that I'm finally getting to Portal 2.
I played the Portal 2 campaign, like the multiplayer
campaign.
I've done that before, But honestly, I would still do it
again.
I would still play it again.
Maybe to see, like, how different it is from playing Portal
2 itself, you know, the main campaign.
Also, look how cute this is.
I was too curious.
I clicked the robot enrichment.
And look at this.
For the co-op, you can customize...
I don't have anything.
But you can customize your little guys.
Too cute.
Wait, I wonder if I can make him look...
more turret like you know this guy is just wheatly with arms
and legs wheatly evolved what's backpack i got nothing in
there and now i have to do the co-op so that i can so that i
can fill up my stuff and then also wouldn't it be so cool to
do some to do some of the online levels as well but yeah
cool i'm so excited let's get back Get into it.
Continue game.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hopefully you guys haven't been like too like, oh gosh, she
really is dumb.
From my gameplay.
You know me, I also just like look it around.
So cool.
Let me in, let me in.
Oh, no?
Wait, so I do need to go this way?
Glados, emergency shutdown, and cake dispensary?
Keep unlocked.
Oh yeah, I totally believe this.
I honestly, truly didn't think you'd fall for that.
In fact, I devised a much more elaborate trap further ahead
for when you got through this easy walk.
If I'd known you'd let yourself get captured this easily, I
would have just angled a turkey leg on a rope from the
ceiling.
Yeah, that sounds awesome.
Oh, oh no, wait, you're putting me back in the toilet room.
But this time, it's a black toilet.
Oh, oh, just kidding.
It was just lighting.
It was nice catching up.
Let's get to business.
I hope you brought something stronger than a total gun this
time.
There she is.
I'm afraid you're about to become the immediate past
president of this.
being alive club uh-huh seriously goodbye oh oh god he's on
fire
why are they setting themselves you were busy back there
well i suppose we could just sit in this room and glare at
each other until somebody drops in idea it's your old friend
deadly neurotoxin if i were you i'd take a deep breath and
hold it where is he oh there he is lately i hate you so much
80 percent corrupt 80 percent corrupt i don't feel corrupt
in fact i feel pretty good pretty good oh that's me they're
talking about to initiate a core transfer Please deposit
substitute core in receptacle.
Oh, okay.
She couldn't even let her to speak.
Are you ready to start the procedure?
Yes.
Corrupted core.
Are you ready to start the procedure?
No.
Oh, yes, she is.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Stalemate, detective.
Transfer procedure cannot continue.
Oh, we'll just give you a one, two.
Pull me out.
Leave me in.
Please don't press it.
Go press it.
Do it.
Yes, do do it.
Don't press that button.
Not so fast.
What the?
What the heck did she just do?
You need to be a trained stalemate associate to press that
button.
You're unqualified.
Oh, it's one of these.
Oh, that's so funny.
It is true that you don't have the qualifications, but
you've got someone far more important than that.
A finger.
All right, we're going to press that button so that she
won't kill us.
Impersonating a stalemate associate.
I just added that to the list.
It's a list I made of all the things you've done.
Well, it's a list that I am making.
Because you're still doing things right now, even though I'm
telling you to stop.
Yeah, huh!
Yes, sir!
Please return to the core transfer bay.
Here I go!
Are you okay?
What if this really hurts?
Bye, Wheatley!
Believe me, it will.
Are you just saying that, or is it really gonna hurt?
You're just saying that, aren't you?
You're just... No, you're not.
Bye, Wheatley!
No, stop.
No, no, no, no.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Would you look at this?
Is he gonna go mad with power?
Giant robot?
Massive.
It's not just me right here.
I am bloody massive, aren't I?
Oh, right, yeah, the escape lift.
I'll call it down.
There we go.
Lift called.
Where is... Oh, there it is.
behind me i could barely see you very tiny shut up it's
significant i've just thought of something how am i gonna
get in you know being bloody massive let me tell you i knew
it was gonna be cool to be in charge of everything but wow
this is cool oh my god he's making a he's juggling
i don't even know what i just said but i can find out oh
sorry no the lift yes sorry Amazing, seriously.
I can't get over how small you are, but I'm huge.
Uh-oh.
No, no, no, no.
Uh, actually, why do we have to leave right here?
No!
We are a huge son of a...
I did this.
Tiny little Wheatley did this.
You wouldn't have done this without my help.
I didn't think she did all the work.
Yes!
Oh, really?
That's what the two of you think, is it?
Whoa!
Maybe it's time I did something then.
What are you doing?
No.
No!
Kratos!
I don't think I'm not onto you, too, lady.
You know what you are?
Selfish.
I've done nothing but sacrifice to get us here.
And what have you sacrificed?
Nothing.
Zero.
All you've done is boss me around.
Where is he?
Where is he getting this?
He's like gaslighting himself into it.
Ah!
What did you do to her?
Oh, wait.
Not the potato.
It's a toy for children.
And now she lives in it.
I know you.
Sorry, uh, what?
The engineers tried everything to make
an intelligent damning sphere on me.
Ideas.
No, not listening.
Not listening.
It was your voice.
No way.
You're the tour.
You're
the tour.
I feel so justified and disliked really now.
Well how about now who's a moron?
Could a moron hunt you into this pit?
Could a moron do that?
Oh.
Uh oh he says.
Oh my god he went mad with me.
power wait the it changed I think the loading screen changed
chapter 6 the fall hi because I'm a potato she's clapping oh
there she is oh that was a lot of meters okay well we are
going somewhere alarmingly fast actually yeah okay he's not
just a regular moron he's the product of the greatest minds
of a generation working together with the express purpose of
building the dumbest moron who ever lived and you just put
him in charge of the entire facility not the clap again
still working hey just in case this pit isn't actually
bottomless do you think maybe you could strap one of those
long fall boots of yours and shove me into it just remember
to land on one foot come here i'll grab you i'll grab you
little potato goddos oh my god isn't there a certain point
where like as you're falling you lose consciousness i think
that would have happened to us by now oh good end of chapter
the fall chapter seven no One thing I really appreciate
about these games is just how fun they...
Oh no!
Wait, I can't move.
No, the bird took our potato!
Ew, suddenly it's half-life.
Ew, ew, ew, ew.
Wait, are there zombies down here?
Um...
But what I was gonna say is, uh...
Just like, you know, they're very witty without having to be
like so crude.
It's just like...
it's just so fun like anybody can enjoy it anybody can enjoy
these games it's my favorite kind of humor i feel like you
know it and obviously if you like like you know dirty humor
or anything like that that's totally fine it's just not my
cup of tea i love games like this where they're so funny
while also just being silly it feels like we're outside but
we just kind of went down down like thousands of feet or
meters Wow oh my gosh I'm this I'm afraid of seeing zombie
I'm afraid of seeing zombie okay so I can go there but is
there where can I use my wait huh is there anything over
here that we can teleport to we can portal to Am I missing
the wall?
Uh...
Arm!
Gamers don't look up, but that's all I have right now.
Feels like we could go anywhere.
This place is massive.
Okay.
I'm searching for...
a portable wall?
Did I miss it?
Can I get burned in the fire?
For science?
I try it for science?
Maybe I do love testing things.
Maybe I do belong here.
I can't believe GLaDOS got picked up by a bird.
Wait a second, there was a bird!
There was one.
Wait a second!
Ah!
I see it now.
The streamer is blind.
Oh, there we go.
Phew.
Almost into the fire.
Oh, there we go.
I'm just gonna say I'm having a good look around.
And
And there?
Where the heck is?
Not there, right?
No.
Okay.
Oh!
Wow!
Woo!
It's so epic sounding.
Suddenly it's...
Suddenly it feels so open world!
What the heck?
I can't believe.
I can believe.
I feel so justified being like I'm gonna crunch this guy I'm
gonna make him into nut and bolt soup I feel so justified
now he's being a little doo-doo head
condemned testing area that's a lot of do not enters keep
out oh are there gonna be zombies for real this enrichment
shaft may contain unsafe quantities of race fallation
elements vitrification order 1961 do not look at touch and
gest or engage in conversation with any substances beyond
this point
imagine you like look in you can't go in but you look in and
see people walking around with head crabs oh zoom
what am What am I zooming at?
Ah, I see, I see.
Wow.
Okay, I made it.
How about...
What's this one?
Oh, blue.
No?
I think it told me about the zoom.
Oh, there we go.
The zoom before?
But I never had to use it, really.
I completely forgot about it.
Ah, I think I'm gonna sneeze.
Please, let me sneeze.
I think it's gone.
Um.
Keep out.
Do not enter.
They say.
I'll open the door for anybody who...
It doesn't even have a handle.
Sorry for not sneezing once again.
I don't know.
I get like an anxiety.
Not a performance anxiety or something about sneezing.
Oh, this is spooky.
Wait, why am I suddenly half-life?
I have no gun for my protection.
Suddenly so spooky!
We're like getting tutorial things again.
Kind of funny.
One, two.
What are those?
Whoa!
Abandonment hatch to test shaft 9.
Zulu Bunsen.
Do not enter.
Sealed 615-19.
Oh, I wish we could go in.
That sounds so good.
Oka!
Override.
Oh, okay.
Wait, do I need to be on the other side too?
Okay, hold on.
I think I have to press the other button like very, uh, when
was that orange?
Oh!
Yeah, I remember how this works.
Where am I?
Oh, we're on the other side.
Okay, wait.
We can do this.
I can't see.
Wait.
Oopsie.
That's fine.
We'll just go back up here and do orange.
So awesome!
Whoa!
Oh, all that for a teeny tiny door.
Oh.
cool i like there's so much detail like the fact you can
hear like running water through the pipes like man man these
games like oh i feel like in a hundred years even they'll
still be so good to play you know what i mean so good oh
creepy way we have a new loading screen i was wondering you
Now, I figured Wheatley would go crazy, but like, I was
curious what else of the game we would do, you know?
I didn't expect to be in such an area.
Do not lean on railing.
Okay!
Everything's so creaky.
That don't sound good.
Oh, old aperture sign signage.
Oh, my God.
I can't get over.
It's too cool.
Oh.
Test chambers 1 to 100.
In 1952.
Vitrified.
Can I get in there?
Oh, we can, we can, we can.
I love the portals!
I love portals!
Detamination area!
Notice, experiment discontinued.
Underground train to test shafts one through eight.
I can't read over here.
It's too dark.
Oi!
Wait.
Oh.
war heroes, Olympians, you're here because we want the best
and you are here.
We already met one another on the limo ride over, so let me
introduce myself.
I'm Cave Johnson.
I own the place.
Cave Johnson?
That eager voice you heard is the lovely Carolyn, my
assistant.
Carolyn.
Rest assured, she has transferred your honorarium to the
charitable organization of your choice.
Isn't that right, Carolyn?
Yes, sir, Mr. Johnson.
She's the backbone of this facility.
Please a postcard, too.
Sorry, fellas.
She's married.
To science.
Sorry, fellas.
She's married.
To science.
That's me.
I'm science.
Wait, I didn't even...
I realized I didn't really, like, look outside a little bit.
Hold on.
Sorry.
I know I'm like, wait, can I even leave?
Sometimes the only thing I wish we had in this game was a
sprint.
Okay, I can, I can.
Hold on, sorry.
I know...
I just wanted to look around.
I got too zealous.
Oh, there really isn't.
There's, like, something up there.
In fact, we'll just put, like, a blue thing right there.
Yeah, a blue portal, so I don't have to walk all the way
back over there.
There's something up there.
Usually it's pretty good about shining, like, a light of
where you need to go.
No?
I guess we'll be going up there eventually.
this is not a ladder this is the tiniest ladder made for the
skinniest person ever that's me I'm so skinny I turned
sideways and I'm literally I'm literally like a PNG I'm flat
enter oh
it made me so dizzy Uh-huh.
Let's see.
Wait, can I even make this?
Wait, I think I can make it if I go over here.
Here we go, here we go.
I was just gonna do it.
I was just gonna...
There's also this area, too.
I guess if we... Whatever.
Through the hole!
God!
That's awesome!
No way, this place is so fancy.
I don't think I can get to the main lift.
Well, there is like that.
I don't know if that...
Here, we're here.
Explore this area first.
There's a thousand tests performed every day here in our
enrichment spheres.
I can't personally oversee every one of them, so these
re-recorded messages will cover any questions you might have
and respond to any incidents that may occur in the course of
your science adventure.
Your test assignment will vary depending on the manner in
which you have bent the world to your will.
So this is like the 67 news.
Those of you helping us test the repulsion gel today, just
follow the blue line on the floor.
Those of you who volunteered to be injected with braiding
Mantis DNA, I've got some good news and some bad news.
Bad news is we're postponing those tests indefinitely.
Good news is we've got a much better test for you.
Fighting an army of Mantis men.
Pick up a rifle and follow the yellow line.
You'll know when the test starts.
No, when the test starts, that's so ominous.
Oh my gosh, people say that my arms are like a praying
mantis.
Maybe I got injected.
I was subject zero.
Please sign in with the receptionist before proceeding to
the lounge.
Welcome test subjects.
This is so fancy.
There he is!
Cave Johnson!
Oh my gosh, Potatoes!
Spirit of Idaho, National Potato Board for the Promotion of
Potato Science.
1955.
Cave Johnson, Shower Curtain Salesman of 1943.
Aperture Fixtures.
U.S.
Department of Defense Contractor of the Year.
Runner up.
1952.
Oh, and we got...
Runner up again in 54.
Top 100 Applied Science Company.
None of these are actually impressive.
Oh, we're number two.
Wow, number two is actually pretty impressive.
Shower curtain salesman of 1943.
Shower curtains were in top demand.
Local entrepreneur buys salt mine.
Cave Johnson to bring science industry to upper Michigan.
The future is here and it's under the earth's crust, says
Science Maverick.
So we're in Michigan?
I need the Oshikats in Michigan.
Oh my gosh, like the ashtrays.
Okay, so we are here.
Okay, well, this was pretty...
Hold on, hold on.
No music yet.
This was pretty easy to get to.
I want to try the other side right quick.
Right where I have that other portal, you know.
You see where I'm...
Oh.
Is there a way?
It doesn't seem like it now, does it?
Aw, man.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, fine.
Oops.
Unless I go from here.
No, I don't even think from there.
It, like, blocks me off, you see.
Okay.
Surely the intention is to have us continue from where I
found.
Oh, dang it.
I'm so curious.
What's over there?
My curiosity.
My curiosity has no... knows no bounds.
We'll just keep onwards and...
If I missed it, if I... If there was a way to get there, I'm
sure you guys would yell at me and say, no, I mean, don't.
He'll tell me.
You would tell me what's over there, right?
The ash trays everywhere.
Wait for an attendant to begin the lift.
Here we go.
Up, up, up.
I love this.
Doesn't Fallout kind of have this type of aesthetic, too?
Like a 70s, 60s, 70s kind of aesthetic?
Was it?
Am I supposed to get off on any of those now that I think
about it?
I guess if I did I could just take the stairs, right?
Where are we zooming at?
Pump station alpha.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, this area has become like ginormous.
Vitrified.
It's so cool.
What does vitrified mean?
What does that me.
I'm gonna google it right now.
Because I don't want to wait until you guys tell me in the
comments.
Vitrified.
Past tense.
Convert something into glass or a glass-like substance,
typically by exposure to heat.
The option of vitrifying nuclear waste presents problems.
That's the example sentence.
Oh, so it means like...
Turn to glass.
A non-crystalline...
Wait, a partial or full transformation of a substance into a
glass.
That is to say, a non-crystalline or amorphous solid.
So they've been like...
They've been put under extreme heat.
Is that a nice way of saying that?
Okay, we're not going to go all the way down.
I see.
Very, very interesting.
Oh.
I said Home Station Alpha There's a, oh there's like a, one
of those Oh, okay, so that probably is our goal But what do
we have here?
If you've cut yourself at all in the course of these tests
You might have noticed that your blood is pure gasoline
That's normal We've been shooting you with an invisible
laser that's supposed to turn blood into gasoline So all
that means is it's working Perfect.
I didn't realize I could click these!
Oh, that's fun!
You might have noticed that your blood is pure gasoline.
Just a heads up, we're gonna have a superconductor turned up
full blast and pointed at you for the duration of this next
test.
I'll be honest, we're throwing science at the wall here to
see what sticks.
No idea what it'll do.
Probably nothing.
Best case scenario, you might get some super power.
Awesome.
Worst case, some tumors, which will cut out.
Which will cut out.
I become full tumor?
If you need to go to the bathroom after this next series of
tests, a test associate no because in all likelihood
whatever comes out of you is going to be cold only temporary
so extreme kidney stones for a week though start worrying
and come see us because that's not supposed to happen that's
not supposed to happen wait now I kind of wish I went back
and saw the other that's fun.
The other, oh, that's so funny.
How am I supposed to get over there?
Cameras don't look up.
I wonder if there were other...
Hmm.
I don't quite see other little things to press, so I guess
they expect you to try and open the doors and that's how you
would know to like because you when you try to open the door
you press it what about here there like this door is so
obvious i need to go there i just don't see where to
transport from gel flow cool there's also light here let the
lights guide you gamer whoa we could just fall to our doom
was there ever an explanation as to why the uh why the
portal gun doesn't work on certain surfaces is that ever
like an explored topic Honestly, I don't know how to get
there.
I don't see, like, something that I can launch from, you
know?
Alright, let's go back over here.
Surely there's something on this side.
If you need to go to the bathroom after this next series,
just a heads up, we're gonna have a superconductor turned up
full blast and pointed at you for the duration of this next
test.
I'll be honest, we're throwing science at the wall here to
see what's next.
No idea what it'll do.
Probably nothing.
Best case scenario, you might get some superpowers.
Worst case, some tumors, which we'll cut out.
Wait, it's fun because you can hear, like, the echo.
It sounds so good.
That's fun.
I don't know.
There's nothing, like, to fall, too.
Oh, look, there was a door here.
That's funny.
Okay.
I think I'll probably die.
When you are...
Can I even go through here?
I'm probably overthinking something.
I feel like I must be.
Because I usually do that.
But I just don't know.
Ah, let me...
Let me do something.
There's, like, not even a pathway for me to walk on.
Unless...
Ugh!
Oh, oops.
I actually didn't mean to do that.
Oopsie.
This is fine.
Where did it stick me at?
Okay, up here.
Oh.
Like, I'm supposed to be here.
This is where I am meant to be.
But I'm just a little confused.
A little confusion.
It's not like I've dropped down to the bottom or anything.
And, like, fly, like, physics myself over.
You know?
Launch myself.
Or do I?
I had a feeling that it might be... I wanted to see what was
at the bottom of the elevator.
Wait, wait, will I make it?
Out!
Okay, one more time.
Maybe like there.
Like there.
Okay, okay, okay.
Uh oh.
Where do I launch from then?
We were so stinking close.
Maybe I go higher.
The launch is real.
Let me off, let me off, let me off!
It wouldn't let me!
Okay, wait, hold on.
I was thinking too, there was no reason for this to be lit
up if I wasn't supposed to go here too.
I know what I mean.
Wait!
Oh my god, I just saw that!
Oh!
Okay, okay, Okay, that has to be it.
Yes!
Oh, wait, I thought my game just froze for a second.
Yay!
Done!
Yeah, game!
I know your tricks.
I made it.
Know your allergens.
Pollin.
Animal dander.
Plastics.
Antimatter.
Oh, everything's so retro.
Know your chemical hazards.
inhale fumes no matter how i was about to say what if they
smell good no matter how good they smell don't touch
anything unfamiliar
gel pressure control i think i'm familiar with that oh
what's down here i think this is probably if you fall if i
had to guess is there anything else in here no Oh my god.
Ooh.
Uh.
Is there anything up there that I need to get to?
Oh, I think so.
Yes.
Is this open?
Nope.
Safety first.
Together we can make 1956 the lowest expected casualty a
numb ever.
they say great science is built on the shoulders of giants
not here an aperture we do all our science from scratch no
handholding no handholding what if was the gel for what did
i turn on what did i power on i mean surely i was supposed
to do that oh i mean it did open the gate for me So I guess
I had to do that.
Golly.
Why did that take me so long to figure out?
There's always something in each part, isn't there?
There's always one thing that, like, really gets me.
Oh.
All right, let's get started.
This first test involves something the lab boys call
repulsion gel.
You're not part of the control group, by the way.
You get the gel.
Last poor son of a gun got blue paint.
All joking aside, that did happen.
Broke every bone in his legs.
live, right?
Oh, so this is Propulsion Gel.
This is the gel.
Remember, the test is unsolvable without an Aperture Science
portable quantum tunneling device.
Look at, dang, look, it used to be humongous.
If you have not received one, please find a test associate
before participating in any Shaft 0-9 enrichment activities.
Propulsion Gel.
It was Aperture's first attempt to create a diet dietetic
pudding substitute it's true the gel is a sweeter slightly
less non-toxic slightly less non-toxic form of fiberglass
insulation that causes subsequently ingested food items to
bounce off the lining of a dieter's distended stomach and
out his or her mouth for various reasons this product was
pulled from shelves I cannot even imagine why.
Whee!
Look at the old school buttons and everything!
Is there supposed to be a...
Oh, wait, there is a...
Where's the button for the box?
Oh, it's over there.
Silly me.
Wait, can I bounce with you?
Oh, nice.
The primitive companion cube.
Oh, okay.
Wait.
Yahoo!
Alright.
Friend.
I'm noticing, like, the graffiti up there of the boxes.
8-1.
The lab boys just informed me that I should not have
mentioned the control group.
They're telling me I ought to stop making these pre-recorded
messages.
That gave me an idea.
Make more pre-recorded messages.
I pay the bills here.
I can talk about the control group all damn day.
Dang.
Yeah, you tell him, Cave Johnson.
You tell him.
So he is like our new Gladys.
Oh my gosh.
We have Cave Johnson.
You know what?
I'll take him.
This was the correct area, right?
I assume.
Oh, I think we go...
Okay, what's over here, though?
I'm just looking around, right, quick.
Oh, there's this area, too.
Wait, whoa!
Ooh!
Their little office, where they...
You can't see anything in here.
How are...
Okay.
Fine.
For this next test, we put nanoparticles in the gel.
In layman's terms, that's a billion little gizmos that are
going to travel into your bloodstream and pump experimental
genes and RNA molecules and so forth into your tumors.
Now, maybe you don't have any tumors.
Well, don't worry.
If you set out a folding chair to the lobby and weren't
wearing leather pants, we took care of that too.
Oh, they gave me a tumor!
A tumor!
Where even is the door?
Oh, look at that!
And there's a second one up there even.
Little cube.
Ah, I see.
Thank you.
Aren't I so polite?
Ow.
Yes.
Dang it.
That could have gone better.
Here we go.
Okay, okay.
There we go.
Much better, much better.
Now this one.
Now we don't want to fall through there.
Now that would be quite unfortunate.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
So we do like a...
Oh, yes!
First try!
Why?
Oh, here.
Do I...
Sorry.
I'm getting lost.
Wait, so...
Is there a place I fall from?
Also, I just thought of it.
What if I accidentally...
Oh, I guess...
Okay, I see it.
I was going to say, what if I accidentally destroyed the
cube?
Another one does drop on there.
Okay.
Um...
Germ!
Do I have to...
Time it?
Hold to prevent bouncing.
Oh, cool.
And we're like, yeah, we know I can get it a little
annoying.
Nice, we made it.
Okay.
In case you got covered in that repulsion gel, here's some
advice the lab boys gave me.
Do not get covered in the repulsion gel.
We haven't entirely nailed down what element it is yet, but
I'll tell you this.
It's a lively one.
And it does not like the human skeleton.
Um, I think I'm okay.
I wonder if, like, it's similar to ectoplasm, right?
I wonder if it's similar.
Hmm.
Interesting.
Fascinating.
Very cool.
I like the gel.
Tasty.
Wait.
All these science spheres are made of asbestos, by the way.
Keeps out the rats.
Let us know if you feel a shortness of breath, a persistent
dry cough, or your heart stopping.
Because that's not part of the test.
good news is the lab boys say the symptoms of asbestos
poisoning show a median latency of forty four point six
years so if you're 30 or older you're laughing worst-case
scenario you miss out on a few rounds of canasta plus you
forwarded the cause of science by three centuries I punch
those numbers into my calculator it makes a happy face I
love it I love that literally everything is very toxic to
you here.
Do not lean on railing.
So I also was thinking, uh, the, the gel does not like the
human skeleton.
Does not like bones, but they were selling it as something
to eat.
Just aperture things, I guess, right?
Exit.
Just aperture things.
Alright.
Alright, um...
Now where do I go from here?
Where do I go from here?
Noisy in here, huh?
Uh, that's where it started.
And...
I don't think I was supposed to go to the other side there,
was I?
Oh, wait a second.
Is there anything wrong?
But I can't...
Are there any other places that I did not look up?
Those gamers?
What if I did, Leon?
Well, I'm going to be a cool guy.
Isn't there, like, what's that thing?
Americans lean so often that if they are trying to train
like a spy, they're like, they have to tell the guys not to
lean so much because it's too obvious.
That then they are American.
Like in another country or something.
I wonder if that's true.
Maybe there's a wall.
I like your style.
You make up your own rules, just like me.
Yeah, I...
The encounter said I couldn't fire a man just for being in a
wheelchair.
Did it anyway.
Ramps are expensive.
Whoa!
Oh, gel!
Wait, can I get covered in it?
Can I get covered in it?
Oh, nice.
I am the bounce.
I am the gel.
There I go.
There I am.
I hate to see her go, but love to watch her walk away.
Okay.
Alright, we're getting really funky with this gel here.
Wait.
If I do get covered in gel, does that like...
Do I have, like, a small amount of time before?
Like, let me get thoroughly covered in gel.
Am I, like, nice and bounceable now?
Oh, that's not a way.
Boing, boing.
Okay, no.
Oh, but what if?
Hold on, hold on.
There we go.
Yeah!
Okay, okay.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Splat.
Nice.
Do it again.
And splat.
And, okay.
We can't get that one, but that's all right.
What if we can do here?
Splat.
What about here?
We're just covering the whole floor.
I'm just doing everywhere.
Everywhere.
You can splat.
Splat.
Nice.
Run!
Is there any way that...
I don't think it's...
Oh.
Do I need to like create momentum or something or...
I don't think it's...
I wish I could do splat.
I wish I could do the gel right there.
But it doesn't seem like I can.
It's, like, really far to the other side.
That's the thing.
So we need, like, crazy momentum.
Like, it's super far.
How can we use it to help?
Wait a second.
What if I do this?
Oh, wait.
I'm stupid.
I did the wrong one.
I got rid of the wrong portal.
Oh.
Oh, that too!
Wait.
I was thinking we have a bounce off of this, but at the same
time...
Oh, wait.
Because it...
Ah!
I think we figured it out, folks.
Folks at home.
I think we got it.
Alright.
So what did I do before?
for?
I think what I did was this, and then this.
I got an achievement.
Master the repulsion gel.
Yes, I'm a master.
Anyway, don't stress yourself thinking about it.
I'm serious.
Visualizing the scenario while under stress actually
triggers the reaction.
I'm a master I was gonna have it Bounce off of the You know,
I don't know how I thought that would work anyway You know
what, whatever, it's fine, I made it We did it, we are
masters Of the jail 1958 Number 27
Now if you're part of control group Kepler 7, we implanted a
tiny Microchip about the size of a postcard Into your skull,
most likely you forgotten it's even there but if it starts
vibrating and beeping during this next test let us know
because that means it's about to hit 500 degrees so we're
gonna need to go ahead and get that out of you pretty fast
what did they do to these people what did they do to these
people
oh you're cleaning up my gel my goo my jumpy goo
it's in here anyway
Wee!
No, I'm seeing that.
We can do this.
Oh wait, it's...
No, we can't even do that!
Oh, come on!
What about this floor?
Just get it everywhere.
Cover the floor.
And jumpy.
And bouncy.
Oh my gosh.
Bouncy gel.
That just soaks it up.
I wonder, though.
Oh, it's so close.
It's so close.
Oh, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
If I can do this.
Ah!
Ah, too much jump!
Too much gel!
I think I have to use this, though.
No?
Wait.
Is it like a momentum thing?
But then what's the point of the gel?
If I'm momentum.
If I'm doing momentum.
But then what's the point of this, you know?
Everywhere.
Gel.
Gel all over the floor.
Gel everywhere.
Oh my gosh.
I don't even know where I am when I do that.
I'm so close!
Maybe like here we do it, we do that.
Right?
Where am I?
Wait, hold on.
Does it cover in here too?
I'm like just covering the floor.
I'm just making a big old mess.
That's what I'm doing.
Wasting all the joke.
What are you for?
I can't go, I can't fly through it, I think, myself
because...
You stupid water, you're throwing off my groove!
it it trips me up it trips me up
I really think if I fly through here, I'll just hit this.
You know what I mean?
Oh, oh, geez.
Oh, geez.
Okay.
No, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, yeah, see?
Is there a way to, like...
I don't know.
I'm trapped!
I'm stuck!
I'm stuck.
My brain is...
My brain is stuck.
Oh my god!
I just noticed there's a button here!
Oh wait, I didn't mean to do that.
Oh jeez.
I just noticed there's a button here.
What does it do?
It turned to water.
Of course it turns off the water.
Oh no, it's timed!
Okay, wait, it's timed.
I'm telling them, keep your pants on.
Alright, this next test may involve trace amounts of time
travel.
So, word of advice, if you meet yourself on the testing
track, don't make eye contact.
Lab boys tell me that'll wipe out time.
Remember, if a future you tries to warn you about this test,
don't miss it.
Let that handsome devil go about his business.
Time travel!
That's exciting for me.
That's like one of my favorite tropes.
Let's get on there.
I'm getting it everywhere right now.
Oops, oops.
I keep doing the wrong thing.
Okay, that launches it.
it.
Oh, that also launches it.
That also, wait, it's like actually in a circle right now.
Oh, whoopsie, whoopsie, whoopsie, whoopsie, whoopsie,
whoopsie, whoopsie, whoopsie.
Whoa, where does it go though?
Oh, it's, it's like going, oh, it's going up there!
That's funny.
I don't think we need it there.
Wee!
Whoa, we have so many now!
Okay, that's fine.
All right.
All right, all right, all right.
Let's just reset it, reset it.
Now...
Oh, gosh, okay.
I'm trying to, like, Like, if I can do, like, a bounce up
here into you, a bounce...
Is it not enough?
Bounce?
Bounce and bouncing?
Okay, wait a second.
Maybe...
This might be silly, but whatever.
Oh, okay.
I'm up here now.
And then we bounce from...
Sorry.
Oh my gosh.
Bounce there and bounce off the wall.
To where we need to be.
Easy.
I'm a master at the jail.
They told me so.
Accidents hurt.
be hurt.
Oh my gosh, he lost an arm.
Liquid.
Co-workers will be hurt.
Oh, accidents hurt.
Co-workers.
Don't endanger others.
Accidents hurt the company.
Replacements are costly.
Accidents hurt.
Science.
That's the most important one.
Investigations impede progress.
Safety first.
Oh, wow.
Okay.
Oh, look at that.
Oh, this is where the jail is going from.
Cool!
We watch it go down.
Fun, fun, fun!
I love seeing behind the curtain.
No?
Isn't that like kind of cool?
And that's where we just came from, so.
I understand your games.
Yes.
Yes!
And also here.
The other side as well.
Yes.
Yes, get nice and soaked.
Full of...
What is up there too?
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Nice and saturated of gel.
Do they have like people coming in and cleaning these off or
what?
I do realize that I'm like a little over time, but I don't
care right now.
I'm soaking it up.
Yes.
Right there, too.
Yes, right there, too.
Everywhere will be covered in goo.
Yes.
Though I'm not...
No, I'm kind of like, wait.
Okay, hold on.
What is the order about?
Because we bounce from there, I imagine.
Maybe I launch here.
Like this.
And then bouncing up.
I covered everything else for no reason.
No, there was a reason.
It was to make it nice and pretty.
Actually, I need to go higher?
Up there?
If you're hearing this, it means you're taking a long time
on the catwalks between tests.
The lab boys say that might be a fear reaction.
Fear reaction.
I'm a psychiatrist, but coming from a bunch of eggheads who
wouldn't recognize the thrill of danger if it walked up and
snapped their little pink bra.
Woo-hoo!
That sounds like protection.
All right, guys.
Fly into space, storm a beach, or bring back the gold?
No, sir, we did.
No, sir.
You and me against the world, son.
Yeah.
I like your grit.
Possible to use the work, though.
Now let's solve this thing.
Let's solve this thing in the next part.
In part five, we shall solve this.
I'm, the goo, I'm getting the goo, I'm getting goo-brained.
I'm getting, the goo is seeping into my bones that I don't
have.
Well, yeah, thank you so much, guys, for part four.
of Portal 2.
And we'll continue next time getting more good.
Let's take our shower, everyone.
Let's take our shower.
Waterboarding.
Thank you, everyone!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
For Part 4 of Portal 2.
And I'll see you when I see you next.
Have a good day, have a good night.
And yeah!
See you!
Bye bye!
I'll tell you later!
Bye bye bye bye bye bye!